ça a déjà été évoqué au printemps CER et
la réponse avait déjà été apportée par
le président du Sénat c'est lui qui a
employer le mot de saucissonnage c'est
une expression charcutière qui lu qui
l'apécie et donc c'était dire non il y a
une politique migratoire elle peut pas
être présentée par par tranche par
morceau donc la réponse a déjà été
apportée nous ne souhaitons
pas que le le texte soit tronçonné il y
a un texte global et la réponse du Sénat
c'est NON au saucissonnage oui un texte
global et un accord global à partir du
texte du Sénat h ce matin dans Le Figaro
Bruno Le Maire appelle la majorité à
reconnaître qu'elle a subi une défaite
et à reprendre la version du Sénat en
espérant je le cite que LR comprennne
qu'il faut bouger les lignes sur deux
points sensible pour notre majorité la
me et les conditions d'accès aux aides
sociales est-ce que cette déclaration de
Bruno Lemer c'est un soutien de poids
pour vous
en tous les cas ça va dans le bon sens
hein on devrait plus souvent écouter
Bruno ler et donc je pense que ils
disent que dit d'ailleurs Gérald
armanin après lui
et et c'est la réalité à partir du
moment où il y a eu cette motion de
rejet à l'Assemblée nationale le texte
revient en CMP et sur la base du dernier
texte voté c'est-à-dire celui du Sénat
donc c'est à partir du texte du Sénat
dans euh son entièreté que se fait
d'accord ou
pas